[Musique]
de l'afrique de l'ouest jusque dans nos
assiettes arrive un grain très ancien
qui tentent de conquérir le monde le
fanu ça fait plus de cinq mille ans que
le fogny cultivé et ils poussent dans la
zone qu'on appelle le sahel c'est au sud
du désert du sahara pas beaucoup de
choses pousse dans cette zone parce que
voilà c'est il n'y a pas d'eau et le
fonio supporter la sécheresse et c'est
une des raisons pour laquelle est
résiliente et kas survécu 5000 les
pierres thiam est un chef restaurateur
new yorkais et auteur entre autres d'un
livre sur le fonio dans des émissions et
des vidéos il propose des idées de
recettes pour faire découvrir ce grain
donc ça s'est pas servie avec du fonio
et ses dires il est devenu l'ambassadeur
du foie new
style et de mes origines je suis
d'origine sénégalaise donc ma cuisine
inspirée de l'afrique de l'ouest le
corps de ma mission c'est non seulement
mettre la cuisine africaine sur une
plateforme mondiale mais en faisant
immédiatement
c'est aussi sauver cette biodiversité il
a donc créé you l'ailé une entreprise de
produits africains à base de fonio
riche en acides aminés en fibres en
vitamines et sans gluten les grès de
fonio ressemble à du quinoa ou du
couscous ils sont toutefois plus délicat
et il se cuisent rapidement
bienvenue dans mon estime alors
aujourd'hui on veut préparer le fonio à
la sauce parachute ça c'est le plat de
résistance mais avant
le chef et de montbenoit sadio est lui
aussi d'origine sénégalaise il prépare
aujourd'hui deux plats typiques qui
l'accompagnent de fonio donc tu vois le
crains petit lafargue rossy dit aussi ça
va bien le venger c'est très riche en
nutriments il commence la cuisson de la
sauce aux arachides le mafé pour le
fonio il assaisonne et verse tout
simplement de l'eau bouillante puis
laisse reposer le temps que l'eau soit
absorbée il termine la cuisson à la
vapeur pour plus de tendreté alors à
vous fournir les preuves pour être servi
regarder ses ventes de foule pendant que
tous les ingrédients de la sauce au
quizz sur le feu ils mélangent aux
légumes et ouverture du fonio refroidi
ou non tu vas voir on va ron on dit que
le fonio n'embarrasse jamais le
cuisinier ça c'est les les bambara du
mali qui dit ça donc donc à dans tout
l'est dans tous les cas on est gagnant à
l'intégrer parce que c'est en fait
un accompagnement qui pousse vraiment
remplacer relie content parce qu'il
faudrait aussi qu'on cherche à changer
nos habitudes alimentaires
au goût de noisette
cette épicerie montréalaise spécialisée
dans les produits africains situe à la
gérante nous fait découvrir les lieux et
ces voiliers c'est en deçà de la
chikwangue du bâton de manioc
ces deux pas de faits de manière qu'il
provient de l'afrique voici les fognon
celui là ça vient du menhir afrique la
marque du plat d'ivoire fournit en blanc
ça vient du mali on a aussi les freins
c'est le même produit mais d'un vrai
changement c'est différentes
c'est un travail des coopératives de
femmes qui dit pile le fouilloux dans
des gants un mort qui est ce qu'il faut
décortiquer le challenge league ce qui
est important c'est que ya pas beaucoup
de monde qui reconnaissent à ma force
d'importer plus en produits alimentaires
en eau sculpteur emploi l épisode de la
streak aussi on est copains cercles
c'est une façon de permettre à ces zones
rurales avec galtier a plu couronnant
parmi les paysans les plus pauvres au
monde d'avoir une source de revenus
d'une façon digne avec leurs produits le
produit qu'ils ont hérité de leur
recette imaginée
par fonio is called the holocaust globe
en conférence monsieur thiam tente de
sensibiliser à l'importance de cette
culture du fonio à l'heure des
changements climatiques pour qu'on
réalise que bientôt la planète aura 10
milliards d'habitants dans cette planète
et et le système alimentaire qu'on
utilise présentement un système il ne
marche pas et il a montré ses faiblesses
parce qu'on se on est limité à attirer à
pratiquement marche du riz du blé du
maïs et du soja alors qu'on ignore
certaines céréales qui sont comme
beaucoup plus le dîner plus excellente
pour la planète va focaliser sur ces
céréales et en faisant ce qu'elle
reçoive la biodiversité mais aussi en
permet aux consommateurs d'avoir des
choix plus intéressant dans leur
alimentation
ingres est à découvrir pour la planète
pour nos recettes et pourquoi pas aussi
pour la cuisine sénégalaise
le sens de la cuisine sénégalaise ne
partage pas ce que déjà à la base en
train pour mange tous au tour de rôle
c'est le plus in de terrain
tout le monde peut trouver son bonheur
dans cette crise
[Musique]